situation facing the NHS in Scotland are
not specific to health services and many
are not within the control of the
Scottish government notwithstanding that
we continue to support our Health
Service to ensure record funding record
Staffing record pay deal for agenda for
change staff in Scotland and progress in
reducing the longest weights in our
National Health Service
sinful is the only way you could
describe that answer from the first
Minister because not a mentioned not a
mention of a patient who waited in
Ayrshire at the tail end of last year
for two and a half days in accident an
emergency the clue is in the name they
went there for emergency treatment and
they sat for two and a half days and the
first Minister her answer to them is
well it's best performing anywhere in
the United Kingdom that is little
comfort for people who are waiting hours
and days for treatment
and the first Minister might not have
noticed but when I sat down raising
these shocking statistics Hamza Yusuf
smiled and smirked the health secretary
thinks it's funny that people are
waiting for days to be seen in a e in
Scotland and the first Minister
mentioned and quoted from the NHS audit
Scotland report into NHS let's remember
BME Scotland settled the report this
morning it is damning of the state of
the NHS currently the report outlines
that Nicholas surgeon's chosen successor
won't meet NHS job targets it says
performance declined further in 2022 the
number of people experiencing extremely
long weeks increased in 2022 and
performance on cancer waiting times is
getting worse every part of Scotland's
NHS is in crisis because of Hamza Yusuf
so can the first Minister tell us is
this useless Health secretary really the
best the s p have to offer first
minister
well in relation to individual cases is
always unacceptable if someone Waits too
long for treatment in the National
Health Service and at the tail end of
last year which of course was Douglas
Ross's phrase that was during the winter
peak of pressure since then in accident
emergencies there are still considerable
progress to be made let me stress that
but we've seen eight hour and 12 hour
Waits reduce and we continue to support
our accident emergency departments in
further progress we are also seeing as
Douglas Ross mentioned recruitment we
have record numbers of Staff in our NHS
right now since this government took
office we have increased NHS Staffing by
28 800 people within the National Health
Service we've got higher Staffing per
head of population than in England or
other parts of the UK we've got funding
that has doubled in our National Health
Service we've got higher funding
proportionately than anywhere else in
the UK to the chin proportionately of
about 1.8 billion pounds equivalent to
44 000 nurses in our National Health
Service and yes we have significant work
to do to reduce waiting times we are
focused firstly on the longest weights
and we've seen significant progress in
reducing the longest weights but the
reason I did make the comparison and do
make the comparison with other parts of
the UK is because Douglas raw stands
here and tells us and asks people to
believe that these problems are unique
to Scotland and somehow down to the
house secretary in Scotland and that's
where they audit Scotland report is
instructive because it says that these
issues are not unique to Scotland I'm
quoting from page seven Scotland's NHS
is not alone in facing these issues and
many of the factors are out with the
control of the Scottish government so we
will continue to do our job working with
and supporting the National Health
Service and we will do that at despite
Douglas Ross's determination to turn it
into a political weapon which I think
we've just seen all too clearly
wow wow
opposition msps raising cases of people
waiting two and a half days in a e in
Scotland is somehow a political weapon
no it's not it's the reality of people
across Scotland just now and the first
Minister loves to make this comparison
between Scotland and the rest of the
Ukraine let's just remember the UK
statistics Authority said Public Health
Scotland's figures and the statistics
Nicholas surgeon uses for the comparison
can be misleading for patients
misleading is what the UK statistics
Authority said now we know that Hamza
Yusuf released a recovery plan that
everybody everybody could see was just a
flimsy pamphlet the first Minister has
now quoted page seven twice of the audit
Scotland report let's go a bit further
I've looked through the whole report the
audit Scotland report says of Hamza
yusuf's recovery plan it lacked detailed
actions
they said he didn't do detailed under
bus modeling he didn't and this is a
quote engaged fully with NHS boards
and information on key patient aims is
missing information on key patient aims
is missing Hamza Yusuf have made the
crisis in Scotland's Health Service much
worse first Minister why should a health
secretary who has failed our NHS now get
to feel the whole of Scotland first
Minister well firstly I didn't suggest
that any MSP raising patient experience
was using it as a political weapon what
I said and what I will say again is
trying to suggest that these issues are
unique to Scotland's NHS is seeking to
use our NHS as a political weapon and to
coin a phrase of Douglas Ross presiding
officer I do think that is shameful on
the part of the conservatives
fine let us look at the progress and it
is the case that we have considerable
work still to do but let's take a 8 and
12 hour a e weights I said earlier on
these have dropped significantly since
the peak over the winter period eight
hour Waits are down by 54.9 12 hour
Waits down by
61.6 that's because of the support we're
giving to the NHS and the work of staff
on the front line look at waiting times
targets more generally the numbers
waiting the longest for treatment have
reduced by almost a quarter for both
inpatient and day case treatment and for
outpatient treatment so there are
significant challenges more significant
than an a point in the history of the
NHS but we are supporting our NHS with
record funding record Staffing and The
Wider support it needs to address these
challenges and that's what this
government will continue to do Douglas
Rose
oh dear eight years ago eight years ago
a field SMP Health secretary became
first Minister Now history looks like
it's repeating itself why why would
anybody risk Scotland's future by giving
a man with Hamza yusuf's record more
power so let's let's just look at his
time in office while the first Minister
gets more Intel from the deputy first
Minister I don't know what's coming
there so let's look at what Hamza Yusuf
has done in office he was transport
Minister who drove without a license he
delayed the dueling of the E9 and he
clapped like a seal when Nicholas
sturgeon lodged a ferry with painted on
Windows he was just the secretary who
did nothing while violent crime Rose got
duped by a hoax video into calling on
the police to investigate Rangers
players and damage free speech with his
heat claim act and now now Hamza Yusuf
is the worst Health secretary since the
evolution but it looks like he's gonna
fail upwards in any other line of work
Hamza Yusuf would have been sacked not
promoted forget being SNP leader why is
he even still in government
first minister
well I don't know about anybody else
presiding officer but Douglas Ross is
sounding pretty scared
[Applause]
he will be as I am sure he will be
scared of whoever is elected to succeed
me as SNP leader
thank you members thank you we also
referred
to the fact I was Health secretary
before becoming first Minister as I am
extremely proud of presiding officer but
let me just reflect on this fact in the
eight years that I have been first
Minister the people of Scotland have had
no fewer than eight opportunities to
cast a verdict on me my party and my
government and in every single one of
these eight opportunities the people of
Scotland have rejected the conservatives
and put their trust in me my party and
my government and I have every
confidence presiding officer that
whoever succeeds me as leader of the SNP
will continue that record of success
thank you question number two Anna Star
Wars can I start by echoing the comments
of both Douglas Ross and Nicholas
surgeon on the ongoing war in Ukraine
and send the solidarity of everyone in
my party with the people of Ukraine
against the tyranny of Vladimir Putin
Nicholas Tarzan and I disagree on many
things and it's fair to say we've had
our Fierce tissues over the years that
I'm sure it will have many more in the
years to come but I think it is
important to note that she has been at
the Forefront of Scottish politics for
20 years and she has served in
government for 15 years and been first
Minister for eight years and in that
time she led our country through a
global pandemic a challenge for any
leader anywhere in the world and for
that she deserves our recognition and
our respect
thank you
presenting the the audit Scotland report
can we please do can we please give Mr
sarwar the courtesy of listening thank
you Jacob said the order Scotland report
on NHS published today makes Grim
reading for the government it supports
What patients and staff have been saying
about waiting times and concludes before
the covid-19 pandemic NHS boards were
already struggling to meet waiting time
standards for planned care and
performance is further since the support
confirms that kova didn't cause the
problems that they were there before
covet but of course exacerbated by covet
after nearly 16 years of SMP government
what went wrong
first Minister well firstly can I thank
Anna server for his uh generous comments
I feel it might be damning him with
faint priests to see he's got more grace
uh in his wee fingers than all the
Tories combined
although I'm sure I'm shooting balancer
out over the course of these exchanges
and finally on that point uh presiding
officer I am definitely showing my age
here when I reflect on the fact that one
of my earlier election contests was when
I stood against Anna sarwar's father
um and my most recent electoral contest
of course it was against Anna sawar
himself and I'm going to spear his
blushes by not pointing out the result
of the latter one even though his father
beat me fairly and squarely back in the
day it looked on into the important
matter of the NHS our NHS does face the
most significant challenges that it has
at any point in its history that is
largely because of the pandemic but as I
have reflected before pre the pandemic
there were challenges in our Health
Service changing demographics ever
increasing expectations of what health
services can deliver in themselves
positive Trends but ones that
nevertheless pose challenges for the
Health Service at what has changed over
the years that we have been in
government well funding for the National
Health Service has doubled it's higher
proportionately than it is in any other
part of the UK Staffing in our health
service has increased significantly we
are seeing in the auditor general in his
report this morning recognizes this
we're seeing the signs of Reform and
Innovation so that we can equip our
Health Service to cope with these
challenges so I do not deny the
challenges but what the NHS needs and
has is a government that will continue
to support it and focus on addressing
these challenges that's the
responsibility of government and that's
what I believe the people of Scotland
deserve and want to see continue Anna
Star War I should say lately that the
Nicholas surgeons need to remind me of
the difference in the 1997 result and
the 2021 result my dad does that often
enough for both of us
um the truth of this government took its
eye of the ball when it came to the NHS
and didn't prioritize the NHS like it
should have done they were prepared and
they still haven't caught up the hill
secretary launched his NHS recovery plan
in August 2021 but according to audit
Scotland current activity is running
well below NHS recovery plan targets
more people are being added to waiting
lists that are being removed from them
and people are waiting longer for
treatment performance against cancer
waiting time standards is getting worse
longer waiting times are negatively
impacting People's Health and finally
the number of people dying each year is
still higher than average things are
getting worse not better the report is
damning and it is clear Hamza Yusuf has
failed he published a recovery plan that
was more about spin than substance and
as a result patient outcomes are getting
worse staff are burnt out and the NHS is
going backwards so does the first
Minister finally accept the conclusions
in audit Scotland's report first
Minister I do accept the conclusions in
order Scotland's report the challenges
on our National Health Service are
significant the recommendations in that
report are important and we will
seriously consider each and every single
one of them staff have been working
incredibly hard and I recognize the
description of burnout that many NHS
staff will feel that is why it has been
so important to give them the fairest
possible pay increase and ensure that
unlike the situation in England Wales
and Northern Ireland NHS staff have not
had to go on strike in Scotland to get
that decent payoffer that has now been
made and as an aside on that issue it to
bring NHS staff agenda for change nurses
in England up to the level of those in
Scotland the UK government would have to
offer a 14 pay increase to them that is
the gap that now exists and but in terms
of our focus on the National Health
Service we have doubled funding for the
National Health Services coming to
office at the budget passed this week in
Palm development increases NHS funding
by a further billion pounds Frontline
spending in Scotland is 10 percent
higher than in England we've got more
staff we've got more staff per header
population than other parts of the UK
and on waiting times yes there is much
there to do but we've seen a reduction
in the longest weeks we've got a number
of national treatment centers opening
this year which we'll see an additional
12 000 procedures able to be undertaken
in the National Health Service although
cancer waiting times are are challenged
as all waiting times are we're seeing
more patients being treated on the key
cancer Pathways so much work to do but a
real focus on this government in
supporting our National Health Service
because that is a responsibility Anna
sorrow it's important we look at the
facts the number of people waiting for
over a year for inpatient treatment when
Hamza user became Health secretary was
22 000 already too high according to
audit Scotland that number now stands
over 35 1000 people when he took charge
of the NHS 84.1 percent of people were
seen within the 62-day cancer standard
now that is just 74.7 percent more than
one in four cancer patients are not
being seen in time and the weak hamster
Yusuf was appointed Health secretary
3448 people waited more than four hours
in a e this week that number is
7572. it's more than doubled even though
fewer people are going to a e on every
single measure this health secret is
failed to get the NHS back on track in
fact this is the worst it has ever been
so does the first Minister really
believe that the man responsible for for
failing Scotland's NHS should be
responsible for our country first
Minister that's a decision for members
in my party but can I say this since
Hamza Yusuf became Health secretary and
this is what Anna sarwar never wants to
mention there have been I think three
for the waves of a global pandemic that
have affected Health Services all across
the UK Europe and the world that's not
something that can just be ignored we in
common with other countries have also
just come through one of the most
challenging Winters that any of us can
remember that's the context for the
challenges in our National Health
Service context that is recognized and
indeed pointed out by the audit Scotland
report today which says and I repeat the
pandemic continues to affect the
delivery of NHS Services Scotland's NHS
is not alone in facing these issues and
many of the factors are not within the
control of the Scottish government but
we continue to support the NHS in the
ways I have set out record funding
record Staffing record pay rise for
agenda for change staff reform and
Innovation to change how patients go
through the National Health Service and
action to reduce waiting times this is
something that is going to take aim to
properly recover the NHS from the
pandemic that's true in Scotland and in
other countries but the focus of this
government will not waver it never will
waver in supporting our National Health
Service and all those who depend upon it
question number three Jillian Makai
the first Minister whether the Scottish
government will provide an update on how
it is responding to the climate change
committees report on progress in
reducing emissions in Scotland first
Minister Scotland is taking action to
secure a net zero and climate resilient
future and doing so in a way that is
fair and just for everyone our Focus
remains very firmly on delivering the
updated climate change plan delivering
on our adaptation outcomes through the
2019 adaptation program and planning for
a just transition across the economy
we're also carefully considering the
climate change committee's latest advice
and plan to respond in the spring Julian
Mackay in recent years Scotland has
shown real climate leadership on the
global stage I'm proud that the Scottish
government is currently Consulting on a
position that would see a presumption
against exploration for yet more oil and
gas in the North Sea while taking real
action to build more solar wind and
Marine Renewables that action must add
up to a plan that delivers on our
climate commitments and delivers our
just transition for our communities
does the first Minister agree that
Scotland's new climate plan will be one
of the most important plans this
government will ever produce and will
she join me in calling on all parties to
rise to the challenge come together and
take the climate emergency seriously
first Minister yes I do agree I think
addressing the climate emergency for the
sake of this generation but also
generations to come is a massive
obligation it is I think a moral
obligation for all of us and I hope
everybody across this chamber would have
the same conviction in tackling climate
change as I do and as the government
does Julie Mackay is right to point out
the need for all countries to move away
from fossil fuels to accelerate the move
away from fossil fuels there's an added
reason why we need to do that in
Scotland because of the maturity of the
North Sea at Basin so even if there
wasn't a climate emergency at which
there is we would have the need to make
that just transition so investing in the
transition investing in the alternative
sources of energy is really important
and of course we are blessed in Scotland
that we have an abundance of those
alternative sources of energy that's why
Scotland is so important it's why our
hydrogen green hydrogen Ambitions are so
important because they allow us to make
the transition for energy needs but in a
way that is just in fear and supports
those who currently work in oil and gas
into alternative employment so that just
transition is one of the most important
obligations of government and why the
updated climate change plan will be one
of the most important documents
published over the period ahead Morris
golden
thank you presiding officer creating a
circular economy is a key component in
reducing emissions a series of reports
by Circle economy assess the circularity
metric of different countries the
Netherlands scored almost 25 percent
Northern Ireland almost eight percent
and after 16 years of SNP rule Scotland
came last with just 1.3 percent why
so
first Minister look there's many
initiatives that we taking to make our
economy more circular to to reduce waste
as well and it's important that we
continue with those but we have much
much more to do that's why we're
committed to a circular economy built
but the conservatives would be more
credible on these issues if they didn't
in a very knee-jerk we oppose everything
that we bring forward to try to improve
performance around the circular economy
like deposit return scheme for example
so so let us focus on what we need to do
better but let's try and find a bit of
consensus in order that the country can
do exactly that and live up to that
obligation that all of us have question
number four Fiona Hislop to ask the
first Minister what the Scottish
government
excuse me a moment Miss heslop can we
have Mrs looks microphone thank you
thank you president officer to ask the
first Minister what the Scottish
government's position is on the future
role of women in driving entrepreneurial
activity and economic growth in light of
the publication of the report Pathways a
new approach for women in
entrepreneurship first Minister on
Monday I had the pleasure of visiting
the Rosalind Innovation Center and was
able to welcome Anna Stewart and Mark
Logan's outstanding report the report
sets out a range of detailed and very
ambitious recommendations at looking at
how we close the gender gap for women in
Enterprise how we do that across the
government education system Enterprise
support networks and wider Society this
is an issue first and foremost the
fairness there are clear barriers facing
women in realizing business Ambitions
including access to Startup and growth
Finance but it's also important for our
economy if women started up businesses
are anything like the men do that would
deliver us significant boost to our
economy as well so this is an important
piece of work and I look forward to
seeing its recommendations implemented
I would also like to thank the first
Minister for the strong leadership she
has shown to women throughout her tenure
this report is an important milestone
for women in business it notes that only
two percent of institutional investment
goes to women-led companies in Scotland
so does the first Minister agree that we
must increase the support for women
entrepreneurs as tapping into this
latent pool of talent is not only the
right thing to do it also has that
potential to significantly boost
Scotland's economic activity and growth
first Minister and I completely agree
with that and thankfulness for that
question supporting women into
Enterprise and closing that gender gap
is as I said in my initial answer more
than an issue of fairness important
though that is it is also one of
economic necessity women of course are
slightly more than half the population
but only around one in five businesses
in Scotland right now are led by women
we need to change that and the
recommendations in this report which
span a whole range of factors from some
of the cultural barriers that women face
to the systemic barriers to things like
access to finance it will all be
important in helping us do so and I
certainly probably from a different
definitely from a different place than
I'm standing in right now I look forward
to continuing to support in this
Parliament at the full implementation of
the recommendations and again let me
thank Anna Stewart and Mark Logan for
all the work they have done to produce
the report
thank you question number five Tess
White
as the first Minister what the Scottish
government's response is to research by
the Royal College of general
practitioners reportedly showing a third
of Scotland's GP staff who was surveyed
said their practice was at risk of
closing in the next few months first
Minister well I will understand the
difficulties that general practice is
facing right now particularly during
what has been and continues in some
respects to be a challenging winter
period so let me firstly put on record
my thanks out to GPS and their teams
across the country a record number of
GPS are working in Scotland we have also
recruited more than 3 000 Healthcare
professionals since 2018 as part of the
wider Primary Care multi-disciplinary
teams and I very much value the work of
the Royal College of general
practitioners they are a very important
partner and the survey is important Obi
I should point out that the survey
sample is relatively small just at 181
Scottish respondents from many thousands
of general practice staff nevertheless
of course we pay close attention to the
findings of it we must encourage more
trainee doctors and Healthcare
professionals to work in general
practice and we'll keep working with the
rcgp and others to ensure that this is
an attractive proposition Tess White
this week GPS in the Northeast have
sounded the alarm that general practice
will become an extinct profession and
they point the finger at a blatant and
shameful lack of support from the
Scottish government that's a direct
quote
freaking Medical Center in bagari
medical center Wallace Town Health
Center Burkhead and hopeman GP service
surgeries and 5e old Meldrum Medical
Group in the Northeast they've closed
will close or have handed back their
contract and audit Scotland have warned
again today that the key Target to
increase the GP Workforce by 2027 is not
on track can the first Minister explain
why the action her government is taking
to address GP Recruitment and Retention
is failing miserably and it's putting
patient safety at risk
first Minister firstly
General general practice is a really
important part of primary care Primary
Care is a really important and
increasingly important part of our
entire National Health Service so we
will continue to support General
practices as part of that wider team I
said earlier on we have recruited since
I think 2018 more than 3 000 Healthcare
professionals to work in these wider
multi-disciplinary teams and we'll
continue to do that in terms of the GP
recruitment Target that's a target for
2027 I believe we are on track who was
audit Scotland rightly says it that will
be challenging but we will continue to
focus on that so that we do meet that
Target and continue to ensure that we
are making general practice an
attractive proposition for those wishing
to pursue Medical Careers these are
extremely important issues and these
times are very challenging for all parts
of our national health service but the
hypocrisy of conservatives in this
chamber really is breathtaking at times
let me just end this answer presiding
officer with this statistic the number
of GPS per hundred thousand of the
population in Scotland is 95 where the
SNP is in office where the conservatives
at an office in England it's not 95 it's
just 78 so yes these are challenging
times but this government is showing and
can evidence how we are showing support
for general practice and for the NHS as
a whole Jackie booley
I'm afraid the first Minister's
government is not on track and indeed
audit Scotland have said they will miss
the target of increasing GP head count
to 800 but it's worse than that because
whole time equivalent GP numbers have
decreased by 200 since 2013 and this
poses a serious threat to the recovery
of primary care at the same time the
number of patients registered with GPS
has risen by over three hundred thousand
yet the SNP have this year cut 75
million pounds from primary care and GP
budgets does the first Minister not
agree that by slashing funding and
failing to increase the number of GPS
the SNP are compounding the crisis in
primary care and ultimately failing GPS
and their patients first Minister I no I
I don't agree with that I do agree these
are extremely challenging times for GPS
and for everybody who works in our
National Health Service the Target in
terms of GP recruitment is a target for
2027 of course we will have to focus and
work to meet that at the graces with
respect to order Scotland and I take
everything they say very seriously I'm
not sure anybody can look to 2027 and
predict what is going to happen they
rightly point out that it will be
challenging but it is important that we
remain on track in terms of GPS we have
seen a GP head count increasing already
by
277. we've seen The Wider
multi-disciplinary teams increased by
more than 3 000 and of course that is
increasingly important because GPS rely
on other health professionals to help
them do the excellent job they do and
come back to the last point I made in
response to the previous question we
have more GPS proportionately than other
parts of the UK I mentioned England
earlier on we've also got more than
labor-run Wales per head of population
and more than in Northern Ireland so
much work to do but we do in Scotland
from position of relative strength
[Applause]
question number six Martin Whitfield
very grateful presiding officer to ask
the first Minister what recent actions
Scottish government has been taking to
keep the promise to young people in care
first minister is the ambition of this
government that every child in Scotland
grows up loved safe and respected so
that they have the opportunity to reach
the full potential regardless of the
circumstances in which they are born
that's the commitment of this government
and it is a personal commitment of mine
that I will take with me as I leave this
government over the next few weeks the
budget that was passed on Tuesday
commits almost 80 million pounds to the
promise and 50 million pounds to the
whole family well-being fund back in
December we introduced the children's
care and Justice bill which seeks to put
an end to under 18s in young offenders
institutions and ensured that children
who come into contact with the care and
justice system are treated with
trauma-informed and aged appropriate
support last Friday I was delighted to
visit East renfrecher to celebrate care
day I always value the opportunity to
hear what matters directly from children
and young people across Scotland as we
work together to keep the promise which
as I say is a commitment I hold
personally as well as for the time being
as first Minister Martin Whitfield I'm
very grateful to the first Minister for
that answer but as she remits her office
many in the care sector are deeply
concerned as to whether the government
will follow through with its pledge to
uphold the promise and I absolutely
welcome the first Minister's personal
assurance that this for her will be a
lifelong commitment but after nearly two
years since the launch and with only
three years to go there are serious
questions about progress so with the
first Minister agree that any failure to
deliver the promise will be nothing less
than an abject betrayal of some of the
most vulnerable children in our society
and will it be herself as first minister
or her successor who would be held
responsible for that first Minister I
will always feel responsibility for the
promise whether I'm in government in
this Parliament or or whatever I happen
to be in in future stages of my life and
I have absolute confidence that whoever
succeeds me as first Minister will share
my commitment to keeping the promise and
delivering on that but let me make this
promise of my own if I at any point
think that this government or any future
government is not doing that then there
will be somebody up there in the back
bench he's been very loud and very vocal
about it and you can hold me to that
cool cap Stuart
I welcome the Scottish government's
ongoing commitment to keeping the
promise to our care experienced young
people can I ask the first Minister how
next year's budget allocation of the 50
million pounds that she mentioned for
the whole family well-being program will
indeed support families that are in need
first Minister the whole family
well-being fund is really important and
something I am extremely committed to
and will want to see uh delivered and
continue to be delivered we talk about
young people in care and it's really
important that any young person in care
is loved and supported and is safe and
secure and nurtured but one of our
biggest responsibilities is to try to
prevent the need for young people to go
into Care by supporting families and
keeping families together where we can
that's the the purpose and the objective
of the whole family well-being fund to
transform services so that families can
access support they need when they need
it and in the way that they need it and
when I was in eastern radio I spoke to
one mother in particular who told me
about the importance of that early
intervention approach and ensuring that
her daughter was able to stay with her
and didn't have to go into care so it's
going to focus on the system changes
required to shift investment towards
early intervention and prevention which
is a critical part of how we keep the
promise in practice the 50 million
investment in this year's budget
includes 32 million pounds provided
directly to Children's Service planning
Partnerships to support work at a local
level and further details of the program
proposals will be confirmed in due
course and many things have been
important to me over my years as first
Minister I'm sure I'll get opportunity
to speak about some of that over the
next few weeks few if anything of these
things has been more important to me
than the promise to care experience
young people our society should be
judged on how we care for and love the
most vulnerable children that we have
and I think this Parliament as a call
not just this government it should be
committed to ensuring that every young
person is loved and nurtured and if we
do that then we'll have something
genuinely to be really proud of
Paul
thank you and I know the first
Minister's personal commitment uh Fiona
McLean of the promise said I quote for
so many care experienced children young
people and Care experienced adults their
lives won't have improved over the last
two years and things will have been
really really hard and may have even
gotten worse it's heartbreaking and
shameful and it shouldn't be the case so
does the first Minister agree that two
years into the promise it is simply
unacceptable that the lives of care
experienced people are still no better
first Minister I I can I thank the the
member for a question I'm not sure if
forgive me if I'm if I'm getting this or
I'm not sure if she was referring to
Fiona Duncan of the promise and Fiona
has said many things done fantastic work
with the care review and and now with
the promise and I know it will be
somebody who seeks to hold all policy
makers and government ministers to
account on this of course course there
is much to do the experience of the
pandemic has been tough for everybody
but for those who they're already
vulnerable and already marginalized it
has been particularly tough so there
will be many respects in which for young
people in care that has been the
experience of the last two years but you
know we talk about the promise and we
have been talking about it I've been
talking about it today in the abstract
we have already done so many things to
improve the experience of young people
in care and when I speak to young people
it is often these things that they cite
to me the the care experience bursary
for example I've spoken to so many uh
Kelly experience young people who've had
the opportunity to go to university only
because of the adversary we introduced
taking some of the other costs away
whether that's Dental charges or or
council tax burden these practical
measures are important because they are
about leveling the playing field and the
Arabic giving opportunity do we have
more to do absolutely we've got more to
do
um and we will absolutely have to rise
to the challenge of keeping the the
promise and I know everybody across this
chamber I hope everybody across this
chamber is as committed to that as I am
and I will be continue to be a very loud
and I hope a powerful advocate for Katie
experience young people as we do
collectively as a science Society keep
the promise that came much later than it
should have done for them but which we
now have all of us have a responsibility
to deliver and Foo we moved to General
and constituency supplementaries and I
call Rona Makai
thank you presiding officer we know the
Scottish government's commitment to the
excellent research and science which
takes place in universities across
Scotland and the impact this has in
patients and communities most in need
given cancer research UK's decision to
withdraw funding from the administrative
base of Scotland's only clinical trial
unit the boots and Institute in my
constituency can I ask the first
Minister whether the new cancer strategy
will reflect the importance of
place-based research in addressing
Regional inequality in cancer in
Scotland particularly in the west of
Scotland first Minister the cancer
strategy will published in the spring
and it will set out our 10-year vision
for cancer in Scotland including
building on the significant stream
Scotland has in research we've recently
published an independent report on
improving Equity of access to cancer
clinical trials and we'll be working
with the cancer research Community to
prioritize the recommendations in that
report and take forward as many as
feasible can I take the opportunity to
recognize absolutely the the very high
quality of research in the west of
Scotland through collaboration between
the bits and Institute University of
Glasgow and the NHS to support this we
have recently increased our
contributions to glasgow's experimental
cancer medicine center which will
receive over two and a quarter million
pounds this year were also committed to
supporting the NHS research Scotland
cancer research Network in running
Innovative high quality research studies
across Scotland Sue Weber
first Minister pediatric audiology
services and NH NHS Lillian have
well-documented issues constituents of
mine have a four-year-old daughter who
suffers from Progressive hearing loss
and has been waiting over 20 weeks for
an assessment at the pediatric audiology
service at Edinburgh sick kids
to my just me the family I've now been
told they must wait a further 11 months
for any assessment with their daughter
currently 778
on the waiting list I hope that is not
too uncomfortable for either the first
minister or the cabinet secretary to
hear
with Progressive hearing loss A quicker
assessment can mean a much better
outcome and life for Annika and other
children like her what will the first
Minister say to Annika and her family
while they wait and wait for what would
be almost one quarter of annika's Life
first minister
in relation to annika's case I would be
of course very willing to look into the
particular circumstances of that I don't
want to see any child waiting that
length of time for access to care and
treatment that the member is right to
see is so important to their quality of
life more generally there have been as
alluded to issues with the service in
loathing and the recommendations that
came from some of those issues the vast
majority of those have already been
accepted and completed and will continue
to work with NHS more than to ensure the
quality of service that everybody who
relies on it has a right to expect
they're on the individual case of course
I will be willing to look into that the
details can be provided to my office
Sarah boyak thank you presiding officer
the first Minister will be aware of
reports today that the projected costs
of the new Edinburgh eye Pavilion have
jumped by 10 and a half million to 123
million given her government shaky
commitment to this vital project and in
the past can she reassure patients
across the lothians and Southeast
Scotland today but edinburgh's new eye
Pavilion will be a priority for The
Scorch government and that our new eye
Pavilion will be delivered by 2027.
first Minister I gave that commitment I
think during the the last Scottish
election I'm happy to repeat it today at
the commitment of this government is not
shaky it is Rock Solid in terms of
construction costs right now obviously
the business case for that will be
interrogated as is at normal for all
business cases we're seeing inflation in
the course of construction right now
which is impacting on the cost of many
capital projects but we have a strong
Capital program in the NHS and more
generally and we are committed to
delivering it Peter swishert thank you
presiding officer strike action across
the highlands and Ireland network has
seen airports including Sombra closed
since Tuesday Shetland patients with the
hospital appointments on the Scottish
Mainland this week have had to have
these rearranged resulting and delays to
treatment and using a precious time and
resource within the NHS hayal is wholly
owned by Scottish ministers so what does
the first Minister going to do to secure
a resolution and end this disruption to
what our Lifeline Air Services first
Minister well can I answer that question
briefly in two parts firstly in relation
to patients whose treatment has been
delayed because of this industrial
action and I know Health boards will be
working to ensure that any delays are
minimized secondly there is a dialogue
on going to resolve the underlying issue
and I would expect how to do everything
possible to reach a resolution to ensure
that any further disruption is hopefully
avoided completely but certainly
minimized
thank you that concludes first ministers
questions the next item of business is a
member's business debate in the name of
Alex Cole Hamilton and there'll be a
short suspension now to allow those
leaving the chamber and public gallery
to do so before the debate begins